hello everyone and welcome to round one
of the 2018 world the rapid and blitz
championship this is from the rapid
section it is the first day of the
rapids and in this well across land
faces an international master from
Uzbekistan crossing has the white pieces
and it's really an exciting game for for
two reasons first the first off crossing
goes for for the fools mate and second
in round one cousin lost a game on time
his time ran out in a well at the time
he said time ran out the position was
equal but his position was very
promising before he actually reached the
position where his time ran out I might
also do a video on that game but just in
case I don't so you know what happens so
this is immediately after that game he
has the white pieces and let's see what
happens cousin opens with E 4 we have E
5 and there is the official broadcast
with every enemy Rose mishchenko and
Peter like oh where they already said ok
for e 5 most likely the rule opus will
be played and then Carlsen just played
Queen to h5 I had the immediately
lunging out with the Queen and what do
you do here Knight to c6 ok the the pawn
on e5 is defended and now comes the
Bishop to c4 already Carson cross and is
threatening Queen captures on f7
and I mean everyone plays this at some
point but if you are a world champion
and you do this at the world's chess
championship then then I mean I mean you
are the world champion you can do
whatever you want but it's most likely
due to the to being angry about losing
game 1 on time but who knows g6 giving
the Queen away also preventing checkmate
we have Queen to f3 again threatening
checkmate
and now comes Queen to e7 defending and
Knight to e2 and now as you can see this
is only move move 5 and already we have
a completely new game on our hands so
this position was never before reached
in in tournament play that's how that's
how funky this opening is nice to f6 and
now comes
d3
Bishop to g7 black ones the castle we
have Nightbeat the c3 Carlson develops
and now comes h6 it seems like night b5
wool will be a very annoying move to
face but but would be sex queen is sorry
our queen is actually guarding c7
everything everything is fine here
tonight isn't really threatening
anything
so after h6 we have Knight to d5 Knight
captures we have pawn captures and now
comes Knight to a5 hoping to grab this
LightSquared bishop and here cross and
doesn't want to go Bishop b3 and allow
this trade so instead we have d6 a very
nice move because you can't capture with
the Queen if Queen captures then Queen
captures on f7 King has to move and then
you lose the dark square Bishop so here
after d6 we have C capture some d6 and
now Bishop to d5 so you've messed up
black's pawn structure you have a very
nice central score for your light square
it's light square Bishop and blacks
Knight is kind of misplaced on a5 so
black immediately brings it back we have
nice to see 6 and now Bishop to b2
cousin continues developing perhaps this
Bishop is coming to c3 at the counter
black strong bishop on g7 we have Queen
to f6 offering a queen trait Queen to e4
and now comes castles by black cross and
also castles and now we have Knights to
e7 attacking the bishop and now Knight
to c3 here Carlsen actually doesn't mind
trading of this Bishop because if Knight
captures Knight captures comes with an
attack on the Queen and also it will be
somewhat difficult for black to develop
his light square bishop at some point
you might want to put b6 but then any
any check could pick up the rook and a
lot of interesting tactics could work
for white so we have Knight to c3 and
now Queen to f5 trying again to trade
Queens across and of course isn't
interested we have Queen to b4 and now
comes Knight captures on d5 Knight
captures on d5 the threat is the threat
is now Knight to e7 with a checker
winning the Queen and here most likely
the best idea is to move the Queen but
here black plays King to h7 and allowed
Carlsen a very nice tactic Carlson
played Knight the c7 attacking the rook
we have looked v8 and here comes Queen
captures on these six and here black
played b6 preparing to develop the light
square bishop and this is the critical
moment of the game here cousin played f3
but there is there is one move that wins
the game for white so feel free to pause
the video and try to find it the move
cousin missed you know it's it's it's
actually a very nice idea so for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are truly an
excellent tactician and for those who
just want to enjoy the show
the reason why it was better to play
Queen to h5 then rather than move the
King to avoid the death fork because
here white would have Knight the e8 and
this just wins the rook wins the
exchange you would have to grab this
night and then you lose the road because
if you try to save it or rook let's say
you go rook to e8 then you get Knight
captures here King captures and now
Bishop captures on h6 the Queen would
have been much more useful on h5
guarding that square King captures and
now comes Queen captures on f8 and now
black falls apart while white is up the
exchange and with with the weak King you
can simply bring a rope make a rock lift
and well it will be over very soon
Carson missed this but it's very
interesting it was it was actually a
sham city invoke edo who was a long time
not calls and Carson was I think some
eight minutes and in his opponent was
three three in some minutes on the clock
but okay we have f3 and now comes the
bishop to b7 now that the dark square
bishop is developed there are no more
tactics as the rooks are now connected
we have route 81 Qasim develops the rook
rook F the c8 and here which Knights the
b5 cross and could still play this game
you do have to move the knight from
being attacked as black is preparing
Bishop to f8 and then after the Queen
moves the knight will be lost but cousin
plays Queen to Bishop to c3 and here we
have Bishop to f8 this is more Carson
missed and now you can no longer protect
the night so here cousin found a way to
at least grab some compensation
he played nice to be
five and now comes Bishop captures on v6
Knight captures on d6 attacking the
Queen and the rook Queen e6 and now
Knight captures on c8 rook captures on
c8 and now rook captures on e5 we have
Queen moves and now rook to e1 so what's
crossings compensation here really he
has a roof for a queen that's not really
a compensation but you know it is it is
as it is better to d5 now all Causton
can do is hope that black makes some
sort of a huge miscalculation in time
trouble we have a four by Carlson and
now comes rushing back to he simply
keeping everything in order a five the
upon captures and now comes King to f1
rope the c5 hoping to trade down you are
up material so you want to trade down
more material that simply make sense
rock capture screen captures and now
rook to a-1 hoping to at least start
grabbing some points d5 with rope
captures on a5 and now Queen to c7
attacking the rook but also connecting
the attack with an attack against the h2
pawn rook to a for a queen captures on
h2 rope captures on a seven and now
Queen to h1 check came to f2 and here
d4 was played and it was in this
position that magnus carlsen
resigned in the game so this is a the
second game he loses in a row and as the
games are currently being played I don't
know how the rest of the competition is
going but surely we're gonna check up on
some other some other games if you have
an interesting day a game that you've
caught feel free to use hashtag
suggestion to suggest it in the comments
as the official broadcast will most
likely only cover a few games so most of
the games they simply don't have time to
show them but but if you found one you
know feel free to suggest we're
definitely gonna cover it but I am here
if you capture then here comes a very
nice idea Queen to h4 check this will
pick up the bishop and if you try to
protect the bishop then you get Queen e1
check King moves and then comes g5 and
this is checkmate as the bishop is
controlling the light squares the Queen
this and the
so a wonderful idea
bye-bye I believe he's 16 years old 16
year old international master from was
Becky Stan and in Rapid Crossing is
rated over 2,900 mr. MCD invoke Yadav is
rated rated 2,300 so the difference is
some 600 rating points so that's
definitely a tough break for the world
champion but you know it happens and as
you see as you saw it's not the problem
that he went for the for the for the
funky-looking fools mate with Bishop to
c4 immediately because at that point if
he played correctly if he found the
tactic he could have ended the game
immediately but you know we'll see how
it goes I don't think if you start with
zero or two you can still win the event
but who knows I'm not gonna say it's
impossible but it will be very difficult
sir I thank you everyone for already
sending me all of the materials for the
subscribers video I will still put the
subscribers video it will be the first
thing you will see in the description
below for those of you who don't know
what it is do check it out below that
will be an email you can use to send me
all of your photos and videos so a lot
of people have already sent be sure to
join them and I would like to thank
Ebrahim Bihari
Delana fiebing's Jordi Serrano Tony
Moore guitar and Nick team for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video so you're
thinking for watching and I will see you
soon
almost likely with some more games from
the world rapid championship 2018 thank
you all and I will see you most likely
very soon